what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel and feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so with Doctor Strange premiering in
theaters this week I wanted to use this
week's verses video as an opportunity to
bring you guys some more content about
Doctor Strange and today we're going to
answer a question that you all have been
asking for so long who would win Doctor
Strange or dr. Manhattan now before you
make a beeline for the comments and tell
me this is a mismatch I want to make it
clear that we're talking specifically
about classic Doctor Strange and for all
you guys who already know this stuff
just bear with me for a minute
so in comics the term retcon is short
for retroactive continuity and it refers
to changes in a character's continuity
that a writer will implement whenever
they want to change the status quo of a
character now this happened to Doctor
Strange in 2009 and New Avengers number
54 under the writing of Brian Michael
Bendis when Doctor Strange relinquishes
his title is sorcerer supreme allowing
the position to pass to Jericho drum
also known as brother voodoo now up to
this point dr. strange had become
immensely powerful and we'll get into
just how powerful later in this video
but after this point and even though he
would become sorcerer supreme once again
in issue number 34 of the second volume
of Venice's New Avengers we haven't seen
Doctor Strange even come close to
approach in the level of power that he
once had it's also important to note
that this event is not the only time dr.
Strange's power level has been altered
as various writers have written stories
in which they try to reduce dr.
Strange's power in order to make him
more relatable to audiences instead of
an almost unlimited force now with that
in mind while pitting dr. strange
against someone as powerful as dr.
Manhattan may seem like a ridiculous
notion at first once we get into some of
the things Doctor Strange is capable of
doing
we'll find out that this battle would be
a lot closer than we might think no the
hardest thing to do here would be to try
and define the power set of classic
Doctor Strange and the reason for this
is that dr. Strange's knowledge of magic
is so vast that he basically knows a
spell to accomplish whatever he wants to
do at any given time and so instead of
trying to figure out what his powers are
we'll look at some of the things that
he's done and some of the characters
that he's defeated in order to get an
idea of just how powerful he is on more
than one occasion
dr. strange has been able to defeat
Dormammu one of the most powerful
demonic forces in the Marvel Universe
that rules his own Dark Dimension and
Doctor Strange has been able to
construct mystical shields to protect
him from dormammu's attacks even as they
tore apart the dimension around him
Doctor Strange is also defeated Galactus
by launching a psychic attack that ends
with Galactus collapsing after shutting
his mind off to escape the terror of dr.
Strange's attack strange is also
defeated an entity known as the
in-betweener who was created by the
cosmic entities of order and chaos which
tells us that at the very least Doctor
Strange was on a power level greater
than some of the cosmic entities in the
Marvel Universe Doctor Strange is also
able to use his spells defensively to
withstand attacks from even the most
powerful attackers as we've seen him do
with the juggernaut in Doctor Strange
sorcerer supreme number 44 and the Hulk
and Incredible Hulk number 299 this is
important to note as dr. Strange's most
glaring weakness is the fragility of his
human body however we see from these
examples that his mystical repertoire
includes sufficient means to protect
himself from physical harm in addition
to this he was actually able to use
protective spells to repel an attack
from mistress death frustrating her so
much that she concedes the claiming
Doctor Strange to the realm of death
would be so difficult that it wasn't
worth the effort now perhaps the most
telling example of dr. Strange's ability
comes from statements made by the
viondra himself now like Doctor Strange
the Beyonder exists in both pre retcon
and post truckin versions but in this
instance we're talking about the prereq
on version of beyond er which is much
more powerful than his post retcon
counterpart this version of the Beyonder
was able to warp reality and manipulate
matter but Doctor Strange was able to
undo his handiwork
furthermore the Beyonder remarks the
Doctor Strange could trap him in a
pocket dimension for all eternity if he
so desired and so the fact that Doctor
Strange could do this to an entity of
such immense power gives us an idea of
just how powerful he is and also
suggests that he has the power to
manipulate matter and warp reality
itself
finally Doctor Strange is afforded
certain telepathic abilities through his
mastery of the mystic arts as well
including telepathy which was used to
overpower the Scarlet Witch during the
house of an event when she was at the
height of her powers and even besting
moon dragon while she was in possession
of the mine gym now while this is just a
sampling of the many feats that Doctor
Strange has performed in his long
history at the very least it gives us an
idea of what he's
capable of and so what I want to do is I
want to turn our attention to dr.
Manhattan now if you're not familiar
with dr. Manhattan he's a character from
Alan Moore's Watchmen comics published
in 1986 he was created when a nuclear
physicist named Jon Osterman became
trapped in a room during an experiment
involving radioactive particles and was
completely disintegrated now while he
was believed dead Jon's consciousness
survives and he's eventually able to
reform a body however following the
reformation of this body Jon is not
human anymore but instead possesses
powers that cause some to describe him
as godlike including the ability to see
the past present and future all at once
as well as producing destructive energy
blasts creating force fields and
basically doing anything he wants
through his ability to perceive and
manipulate atomic and subatomic
particles in addition to this dr.
Manhattan has an impressive list of
feats as well despite having only
appeared in a 12 issue watchman series
and subsequent prequel miniseries called
before Watchmen dr. Manhattan for
example he's able to vaporize enemies as
we see him cause the criminals head to
explode as well as disintegrating his
teammate Rorschach and so basically what
we have in dr. Manhattan is a walking
almost omniscient atomic bomb something
else to note is that he's able to
manipulate matter since he's able to
construct a fortress on Mars from the
matter within the planet add oxygen to
the atmosphere so that humans can
breathe and create water out of thin air
he also possesses telekinesis as we see
when he's able to move and levitate his
entire fortress and can also render
himself immaterial and phase through
solid objects that we've also seen
several instances of him being able to
teleport across long distances and can
even teleport himself from Earth to Mars
and during the events of before Watchmen
he also demonstrates an ability to
travel through time and so the question
becomes who wins between these two
almost immeasurably powerful beings well
while there is room for argument I think
the win here actually goes to dr.
strange now dr. strange is said to have
vulnerabilities against enemies who are
strictly science-based
which would include dr. Manhattan but
this is a weakness that dr. strange can
actually overcome what I really think
tips the balance in favor of strangest
power is that we have so much more
evidence of his power than we do of dr.
Manhattan we do know for example the dr.
Manhattan is powerful and we've been
told that he has godlike powers but if
we're basing this on what we've seen him
do I think dr. strange would have an
answer for all of it in addition to this
dr.
and Hatton most likely would try to
vaporize dr. strange but dr. strange has
proven his defensive spells are strong
enough to withstand attacks from
powerful enemies and furthermore we see
the eye of agamotto protects him from an
atomic bolt and strange tails number 166
so we know that at the very least he's
able to withstand atomic attacks which
would include anything within dr.
Manhattan's arsenal the problem with
this and what we don't know is how dr.
Manhattan would fare against a magical
opponent as magic does not seem to exist
in the Watchmen universe at least not as
far as we know as a result we've seen
nothing to suggest that dr. Manhattan
would be able to do anything to counter
dr. strange removing him from this
dimension and placing him into a pocket
dimension as it's been established
classic dr. strange was capable of doing
and so at this point because we simply
don't have any evidence that dr.
Manhattan could do anything that dr.
strange couldn't counter we kind of have
to declare dr. strange as the winner but
that being said dr. Manhattan has
appeared in the DC Comics as part of DC
rebirth what the limits of his powers
are is something we don't know but until
we actually see a definitive load
provided by DC again
I gotta go with dr. strange on this one
but with that being said if you guys are
new here to colors explain be sure to
hit the sub button become part of the
robb core and if you guys want to see
more videos like this drop a like and if
you guys have your own stance on who you
think would win or if you have ideas on
what characters we should pit against
one another when it comes to our vs.
series whether it's Marvel vs. DC or
image vs. DC or image versus Marvel or
valiant or so on and so forth then post
a comment down below and let me know
which heroes we should pit against each
other and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you